look at what the Soviet Union did look
what they do in North Korea you look
what the Chinese have done you don't
even want to get near or anything like
that
everybody thinks oh well you know this
country's so stable and we have a
democracy and we're always gonna be that
way I mean we're the oldest surviving
test of a democracy in history we're
vigilant and we have a constitution that
protects rights and I don't think we
should be giving rights away so easily
and some people say well you know there
is no right to privacy in the
Constitution well there's not it's been
interpreted that way and ironically you
know roe v wade and interpreted 1973 the
abortion case interpreted that you have
a right to privacy and I'm not ready to
give that away and some are I don't know
welcome to Maryland when a series of
violent crimes were captured on video
cameras the legislature considered
adding audio surveillance to its fleet
of buses operating across the state the
microphones can help to stop crime but
they can also pick up every detail of
conversation along the ride in
sponsoring the microphone bill delegate
Melvin Stokes unleashed a statewide
debate over private speech in public
places if you were sitting in your home
at your table in your bathroom and your
bedroom your den or whatever you should
be expected to be able to have a private
conversation but you when you get on
public transportation which at certain
times of the day you will be shoulder
the shoulder elbow to elbow breath the
breath how can you expect to have a
private conversation it is definitely
not it's a question the courts have
struggled over for a century in 1967 the
Supreme Court interpreted the Fourth
Amendment's prohibition against
unreasonable searches as a
constitutional right to privacy writing
the majority opinion in Katz versus the
United States Justice Potter Stewart
declared what a person knowingly exposes
to the public even in his own home or
office is not a subject of Fourth
Amendment protection but what he seeks
to preserve as private even in an area
accessible to the public may be
constitutionally protected
justice stewarts decision says our right
to privacy doesn't matter where you are
it only depends on what you expect so
the question is do you expect any
privacy on a public bus it's almost an
invasion of privacy but when a crowded
bus you wouldn't normally talk about
things that are private on the bus by
going on the bus you're accepting that
that's one of the exchanges that you're
making and I think that's a reasonable
one so you wouldn't be like talking
about your like social security number
on a bus in public
I choose privacy doesn't bother me
because I'm not doing anything to
disturb anyone because I don't like to
let everybody know my business I'm fine
with it because if it's gonna help
there's a lot of idiots on the bus
sometimes the invasion of privacy is
never worth it to stop crime because
it's a tough question in trading privacy
for security the citizens of Baltimore
are following the national trend towards
greater acceptance of public
surveillance but surveillance was never
the citizens choice to make after the
state assembly rejected three audio
surveillance bills the Transit Authority
acting on advice from the Attorney
General began activating microphones on
hundreds of buses across the state but
before they could be switched on the
state had to overcome Maryland's
restrictive wiretapping law in order to
record anyone the law requires the
consent of all parties the Transit
Authority dealt with this restriction by
posting warning signs on every bus it's
a solution that's being replicated in
cities all across America now we're in
this new stage when we have drone
technology and audio taping technology
that can do voice matches that can pull
things out and this it's a whole new
world now and the question is what do we
want this world to look like and if
legislators don't start to find the
parameters government will they define
the parameters and the government's
parameters are there are no parameters
we can do whatever we want his putting
in a bill to stop it we had that bill
had to be killed I went and testified
this time before the Senate about what
was occurring across the country what
makes Merlin so different that you want
to stop and take a tool away from me I
worked there I deal with this every day
I deal with this complaint I feel the
pain of these people I go out and I ride
this whole slippery slope theory that
some people are concerned about is I
mean they've said and demonstrated this
is what we want to do we want to expand
it to every single public ridership
arena that we can I won't hear his side
of the story it was a simply of respect
from one colleague to another one side
of the hall to another and I said what
you've got is misinformation and you're
taking misinformation and you're trying
to use this to stop something that it's
not illegal
there was a very intense debate and
people were and there was nobody who was
on the fence on the Syst show there are
people like oh yeah what's the big deal
and I'm like are you kidding me
I've got the truth on my side here is
the letter from our Attorney General dad
this is not illegal what more he is
attorney for all the state of Maryland
what more do I need in the end delegates
Duke's needed nothing more senator
Brosius bill to bar the Transit
Authority from conducting audio
surveillance in Maryland lost by a
single vote on the Senate floor this is
a right to privacy and I just think some
people in the legislature in the Senate
they just didn't get it you know that's
a pretty big deal I'm just gonna say we
prevailed in the end it was a hard
struggle Maryland won the right to
record its citizens in public places a
victory for security but while the state
is free to record you don't think about
turning your camera on the state the
same wiretapping law that allows law
enforcement to record citizens of
Maryland makes it impossible for
citizens to record law enforcement
so even if anybody's voice or anything
else I got slow instead of Maryland me
favorite please the Transit Authority
denied reasons request to enter this
command center where Baltimore
surveillance is monitored and after
attempting to photograph a few
surveillance cameras inside of a city
bus the bus was stopped and the driver
forced me to leave knowing how nervous
Baltimore bus drivers can react I
decided to leave the bus but by failing
to get anyone's consent even inside of a
bus that was listening to all of us with
cameras I wondered did I violate the
state wiretapping law the future is that
if legislators like me don't say no this
is inappropriate bring it to the two
legislative bodies in different states
and and nationally that this dead
government is going to think that this
is the norm there's a lot of catchin up
the government has to do to try to
protect his citizens thank you Lord for
the cameras that ball so hit up the on
the on the on the minute on if those
cameras didn't exists these guys might
still be out to you I think it clearly
crosses the line and we better find a
line now because if we don't the
government will find that line for us
and that's exactly what they're doing
right now they're defining the line and
government shouldn't be defining the
line that the people who government
represents should be defining the line